der köche verderben den brei
wenn sie der presse an dem gleichen
arbeiten dann wird dann wahrscheinlich
mich und schmecken
dieses sprichwort weit weg von auch auf
andere zusammenhänge
wenn man zb in einem meeting ist und man
aufgaben verteilt dann will man
möglichst nicht so viele leute haben die
an der gleichen sache arbeiten denn das
mit nur kasse wie findest du meinen
neuen blade ich werde das nicht anziehen
aber das sind ihr gut und hat durch die
blume sagen heißt dass man eine
unangenehme wahrheit versucht etwas
sanft auszudrücken
tschuldigung hatte denn vorstellt weiß
ja gar nicht schlecht also wie waren
eigentlich wenn man etwas im halb hat
und man nicht richtig sprechen kann sich
also reichsbahn muss dann sagt man im
deutschen mann hat einen frosch im hals
wenn man auf deutsch den ausdruck ins
gras beißen benutzt heißt das dass
jemand gestorben ist
ala ist aber zu denken ein schauspieler
er ist natürlich alles ist natürlich
nicht echt gestorben aller welt noch mal
das wort wenn jemand nicht integriert
ist sondern wirklich teilen der
gesellschaft also nicht integration
[Musik]
inklusion in einem etwas auf der zunge
liegt heißt das dass man sich an ein
wort erinnert man kennt dieses wort aber
gerade in diesem moment fällt es einem
nicht ein
und ich finde der ist wirklich gemeint
gewesen
doch aber der hat doch also ich wäre das
schon er hat doch auch du musst auch
immer deinen senf dazugeben seinen senf
dazu geben heißt dass man seine meinung
zu etwas äußert und oft benutzt man
dieses wort wenn man eigentlich nicht
möchte dass diese personen jetzt auch
noch ihre meinung sagt am werk du musst
auch immer deinen senf dazugeben und
reingeschüttet
[Gelächter]